Halle, I understand there was
a bit of romance for you, you fell in love on the set.
Is that true?
(whooping)
I did.
That's what I heard.
There was a rumor that you fell in love on the set.
I did, but my castmates don't know about it.
Why you gotta bust me out.
That's my job.
Who told you that?
First of all,
I don't know what bust me out means, second,
(audience laughs)
the reason I'm busting you out
is 'cause that's my job to reveal interesting information.
I did, there was a boy,
yeah, there was a boy.
(audience cheers)
I guess the reason I liked him is that he was very quiet.
He did whatever I said, let me have my way.
Perfect, perfect,
These are the things
you like, I think we have-
Perfect guy.
We have a photograph here.
His name's Charlie.
[Conan] There we go.
[Audience] Awe.
[Conan] You really bonded with this horse, didn't you?
[Halle] I bonded with Charlie, yeah, I did.
So, people forever have been tryin'
to figure out how to make you love them,
and they just needed to act like a horse?
(laughing)
That's it?
That's as simple as it is?
Yeah.